le monde this could i aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur octobre date dhabi as catch
ok on est actuellement en train d'entrer
le dit proche aux arts faut que je
retrouve les touches tactiles anges ce
jeu excède ça te rappelle un peu comment
ça se passe car andrew ladd et eva tube
je suis à ma fille coup de tentacules ok
on va devoir danser c'est quoi ce délire
et bien évidemment qu'il est fort dans
ce genre de trucs regardez ses jambes
pour deux fois la taille de jambes
d'animaux ouais ça a bien trop vite ça
c'était la danse de la poupe
c'était intense et très émotionnel
maintenant ok j'ai fait un câlin avec ma
jambe
c'était carrément dégueulasse à mais
désolé mais aussi dans l mais ne ferme
mes soeurs a changé pour rejoindre est
quand je ne serai plus tôt
elle a dit que si c'était s'avère qu'ils
étaient dans cette situation il y aurait
pris là-bas et du coup elle me dit que
bois va je lui laisse un peu plus
d'indépendance et je suis gentil
c'est juste qu'elle est dans le noir
elle prends ma main et elle fera un peu
comme ça quoi en fait les scientifiques
les reconnaissent les poissons à 120 m
et du coup agnès elle m'a laissée passer
c'est bon si on fait ces scientifiques
la peau voilà il voit très vite les
poissons voilà comme vous pouvez le voir
aw elle a l'air de bien marcher la
traction à le sont dégueulasses qui
grésille est bas viens viens on va on va
dans la bouche du requin fils tonnes on
va s'amuser un regarde regarde comment
on est bien déjà qu'ils réparent les
panneaux électriques avec une scie est
ce que cette pieuvre est un gros bourrin
mais tout est emmêlé les futures ont
baissé la guerre au sol puis si ces
[ __ ] de tentacules c'est des câbles
ou si c'est si ses tentacules
s'il vous plaît dont je ne veux pas
danser avec vous messieurs les câbles
doigt les clubs à voile a quand même
non ok donc c'est un truc quand ils se
débrouillent chez ceux des branches
d'une manière car mon corps bon bah ça
va alors ça mais vachement confiance de
doit réparer soi-même et d'attractions
qui ne marche pas à voilà qui me fait
bien plaisir et le dernier qui est
probablement hop
mais non monsieur l'étagère madame
l'étagère pardon enfin je veux dire
c'était pas une belle étagère quoi on
aurait pu confondre son sexe à m'énerver
l'ua arrête de chatouiller c'est pas ça
que je veux et octo dad
ah bah voilà enfin c'est pas trop tôt sa
voix est et si le bayer ne retire et si
je suis là voilà vient stacy rejoint
mois elle s'est crue sur un tapis
roulant koala un pied aux fesses
escalators la nouvelle émission proposée
sur france 2 tous les midis à 13 heures
à la place de inspecteur derrick fou ok
faut que je trouve tout mis oui mon fils
voilà le mec qui a le métier le plus nul
du monde se baladait déguisé en requin
marteau dans un aquarium aa et faire
semblant d'aimer ça aussi hop on s'en va
escape est ce qu'elles disent y voit la
technique tom cruise version pieuvre
c'était ridicule
attendez on va passer par là bas je peux
passer là vous pensez vous pas non non
c'est la défaite attendue va tenter un
truc idiot
c'est ridicule
on a mesuré une sorte de karrada non non
non non on m'aurait jamais qu'à moi
c'est fait preuve je veux passer s'il
vous plaît monsieur je vous le demande
avec ma jambe
laissez moi passer à le voilà je veux a
misé à fond je trouve les villes
elle est là on revient attendait mais
est ce qu'on est en train de jouer a dit
bout là c'est ça sa récompense lui c'est
un toboggan moi qu'est-ce que je fais
moi je peux prendre le toboggan ou pas
oh merde
oh merde ah bah voila quoi je dois je
dois escalade et ça c'est mes gars dur
peut-être avec une tentacule oh oui what
is haut vol il s'écrit dans gravity la
non très clairement
sandra bullock est ce que c'est toi ah
je me connais ton cauchy une pieuvre qui
se prend pour superman
la pieuvre hamster mais j'aime beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup c'est vraiment mignon tu
comme ça voilà il paraît que c'est bon
pour pour rien du tout en fait de faire
ça allait je m'en vais l'esma une sorte
d'élastiques qu est hardcore katende jeu
c'est bon je sais comment faire ici
voilà comme un gros gros tricheurs que
je prenne cela et que je le mette dedans
voilà le gros tricheurs
allez c'est l'heure du toboggan ah oui j
mais avant toi mon fils a je crois que
tu avais pas envie de génial
oh et le chat gaulle c'est le fils de
zidane il a juste le crâne chauve film
aux mondieux l'attraction de dingue je
suis violent c'est compliqué c'est bon
j'arrive fiston regarde je suis c'est
bon voilà salut je suis un enfant moi
aussi ouais
sympa la corde au pire la ddt mokdad que
ton il fait voilà laissez-moi monte
tranquillement au oui ça c'est beau ça
ça c'est non non non à temps qu'on a
accroché un pied ou une fille je fais le
drapeau un verbe [ __ ] je dois toujours
taper c'est l'heure de la poulie après
ces peintres ou salut ça va j'essaie
juste de passer par le trou tout comme
toi voilà c'est vous et là on croit que
c'est son bras mais en fait c'est son
pied pas [ __ ] enfin non non trop de
pression ouais c'est l'heure du thé
roggan non je ne vais pas faire des
donations et je vais pas acheter truc
donc par contre je vais voler ce truc
voilà et bah c'était bien sympa ce petit
niveau
alors on va rejoindre notre femme du cou
ou ça donne un peu envie de vomir au
scarlett sas a voulu non il nous a vus
c'est un piège au nom nous a mis tout nu
aux mondiaux retourne là d'où tu viens
non non non [ __ ] oh non on s'est trop
triste je t'aimais vont aussi hauts que
de bas
j'avais même préfet de t'offrir un cd
avec nos plus belles photos de vacances
s'ils trouvent sur un bateau il faut pas
qu'on se fasse détecter apparemment
attendait mais là on se croirait
vraiment dans un splinter cell quoi sert
cette version pu être ok il faut que
j'aie un déguisement y est oui je suis
le capitaine
oui pas de problème je vais à la roue
comment est-ce qu'il ne boit pas la
douche était très chaude à des buts à
chaque fois à chaque fois je me fais
avoir avec ces [ __ ] de porte
je ne sais pas capitaine
c'est un escroc une pieuvre qui avait
tué d'une famille qui a fait une fille
et on va tous retirer je me vengerai de
la balade coach ceux ci étaient là c'est
la moins crédible de tous les temps
cordialement c'est moi j'ai trouvé non
mais non mais attends attends on fait je
pense qu'on peut passer entre les deux
marches
[ __ ] c'était tout court merde salut je
suis le capitaine hier où joue je suis
le capitaine
oui je suis très viril qui es tu c'est
scarlett
non il nous a trouvés pendant coup
parler à une femme il a l'art de bien se
cacher tu vas pas vu tu vas pas vu non
alors il faut que je mette sur la gueule
tiens tiens alors faut que je me casse
en fait non à dieu
battus à bordeaux même si c'est bon hop
allez moi poisse te faire lâche la porte
et boum
oui mon dieu au cfai chef je te
retrouverai toujours avoir dans la
pierre au cc l'octopus dance os il a
l'air tellement heureux d'allier une
encre qui s'est incrusté dans le délire
moi je dis ça je dis rien en la balance
c'est pas moi ah c'était il est il a
juste imaginer tout ça le regarde et
comment je me déplace quoi ces trucs
carrément trop chaud oula oula oula oula
leur car arrivant à traves circuler
laisse moi tranquille tu ne mourra
jamais attendez mais on va aller
jusqu'où comme ça là on est dans
l'espace là ça y est ok vos corvées
juste en train de faire le marathon de
l'aquarium n'y a pas de problème c'est
le parcours du combattant version
pieuvre donc qu'une pieuvre à mal elle
fait se brûlant d'un truc ça servait
qu'à un moral qu'on fasse un tour
d'aquarium les enfants vous avez vu
votre père ou est ce qu'il peut bien
être
oh elle m'a reconnu au gd mauvaise
nouvelle pour votre mari il a un pif c
une brique il peut concerner maison avec
son pif en eau et va leur dire la vérité
get to the cafétéria passant ma tortue
[ __ ] mais lui m'énerve jusqu'au bout
il va me faire chier
attention james bond
[Musique]
allez passe en dessous la discrétion de
merde c'est bon on est extrêmement
discret metal gear solid version pieuvre
merde faut que j'aille là dedans des
chiottes y est ok faut que j'aille là
dedans allez allez allez et cher pour
nous et aujourd'hui bienvenue dans un
dîner presque parfait jean-michel va
nous faire un grille pain au micro ondes
finalement jean marie change de plats il
va faire une pieuvre au micro-ondes
assez bon ghrifa dans le micro-ondes
leave the bricout maire vite c'est bon
allez on passe sous la porte
tu avais ya vraiment des situations vais
aux [ __ ] à la grosse mission qui
s'annonce mais comme par hasard iphone
déménagement les make up y ait au [ __ ]
c'est pas moi c'est pas moi c'était
temps des kz j'aimerais rentrer là
dedans voilà c'est bon on aurait dit que
c'est lui qu'on allait servir sur un
plateau à quelqu'un or voilà ma famille
mais il est sérieux mais qui ligotent
les enfants je vais te défoncer au mode
de vente par famille voit que je suis
une bio ça explique tellement de choses
alors me dis pas que ma fille vraiment
beau donner quand même
ok je cours aillent le feu sacré je veux
pas brûler ça fait rire le mec qui fait
20 cm qui va regrouper recuites oreilles
qui fait des bêtes
oui je suis là ma femme je suis là mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ça l'avait
spider man voilà ce pays normal à perdre
non
[Musique]
oh
la salle épique aux mondiaux il nous
lançons dh enflammé ça n'a aucun sens
obtiennent la la la la la
oui est ce qu'on à tuer le malade toc
propos est tombé s'est retrouvé là
d'accord ok enfermé dans un abat-jour
très bien j'ai pas de problème alors à
un regarde comme je te mets des petites
claques un peu alors ça fait moins le
malin hein
j'étais juste un cas l'homme part comme
ça c'est quoi ça aussi si papa est un
acte opus mois est et si on vient d'où
on a fini le jeu les gens ça y est allé
pop corn pour tout le monde c'est la
fête
et voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin de
cette petite aventure sur le nouveau
octobre est qui était quand même bien
marrant oui oh oui oh oui oui il faut
dire ce qui est oui n'hésitez pas à me
dire en commentaire ça vous a plu ou
nous en ayons la vidéo non en tout cas
on se retouve mercredi soir dans une
nouvelle vidéo chat au monde pis quand
c'est vous bien à bientôt
edit xieme les beach et bichir reste on
prend pas pour ses connectiques aux
brenets
salut